[Music]
do
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so we have five film profiles and lots
for sony cameras i also have a surprise
for you so stick till the end to find
what it is
first off this video will be a brief
introduction to the profiles showing all
the settings i've used and sample
footage for each
if you're interested in a more technical
comparison let me know in the comments
and i'll make a different video for that
okay let's get started
i'll start with one of my favorite
profiles
vectro 100
which initially was made for street
photography
having rich and deep colors with punchy
contrast
compared his profile to velvia film
simulation or kodak portra 160.
this profile is good out of the camera
and requires no color grading
i find using it in most situations even
in low light
but since it's so contrasty you will
have to bring up the iso quite a bit
if you don't mind the noise you'll love
the results it gives at night
[Music]
the next profile is actually my favorite
profile for portraits
and it's called senova light
[Music]
[Music]
softer contrast than vectro 100 with
more pink desaturated tones i believe
this is the perfect profile for skin
tone
i really do love the saturated vintage
look it has to it and i don't find the
need to color create this profile at all
[Music]
even with a detail level down to seven
on all profiles i still find the sony
footage just a little bit too sharp so
for basic correction and davinci resolve
i just bring down the mid tone sharpness
and add some film noise
if you only do these steps you'll notice
it will get rid of all the digital
sharpening and make it look better and
even more filmic
[Music]
[Music]
the next profile
is fuji 400
the fuji 400 gives a beautiful balance
between colors and tones with muted
blacks red shifted towards orange toned
down greens and blue shifted towards
magenta it really does give a dreamy
color palette
besides the sharpening and adding some
film grain i don't feel like color
grading this profile either because of
the beautiful colors that it gives out
of the camera
[Music]
[Music]
it's really hard to choose a favorite
from all these profiles because each of
them has unique features
but if i would have to choose only one
profile for any situation it would be
eve pro plus
with the best noise ratio with soft
creamy gradations from shadows to
highlight this profile is my absolute
favorite which made me use it
confidently for ninety percent of my
work
i cannot praise this gamma curve enough
cine 1 has 109 output which means you
can easily recover burn highlights
also as the cine gamma with the lowest
contrast
which gives you more flexibility in post
i have saved a daytime version and a
nighttime version with lower contrast
for really dark scenarios the night
version can be used even daytime for
more latitude in post
[Applause]
this profile is my first choice for any
project because i know i can trust the
results it gives me and can easily be
further color graded in post
the next profile is definitely the most
artistic profile and will give you the
closest look to film bluish greens and
the saturated tones with crushed shadows
and highlights this is the perfect
filmic profile
the second profile with the best skin
tonalities giving a neutral mute color
it will make everything look more
interesting
definitely one of my favorites with a
very specific look it can be used in
various situations from street to
portrait nature and sometimes even
product commercial
[Applause]
generally with sony i recommend shooting
500 to 1000 kelvin below normal because
i find sony sensors just a tad warmer
than other camera brands
maybe also add a little shift towards
cyan or green in the color filter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so here we are at the end as i promised
i have a surprise for you
we have three more picture profiles that
i want to share with you
the first profile
is made after portrait 800.
leave the color grading behind and get
the most dynamic range out of the camera
because this profile has a super soft
contrast and increased saturation giving
you a candy look
just like portra it has the most dynamic
range this camera has to offer and the
base iso starts at 800.
so this profile gets rid of all the
nasty green hues in the skin tones most
sony users are experiencing with s-log
and it's pretty much good to go out of
the box depending on preferences you
might want to bring down the shadows a
little to increase the contrast
the next profile is called kodak gold
i want this profile to really give you a
golden look offering the richest yellow
and red from all profiles and requires
no grading
like i said i shoot 500 to 1000 kelvin
below correct temperature but only with
this profile i recommend bringing up the
kelvin or the color filter towards
yellow or red to emphasize even more the
warmer tones
[Music]
the last profile is called cine steel
50d this profile is going to give you
really interesting color rendition with
earthy skin tones and velvety blues it
really does stand out for the name
filmic profile
so here you have them these are the film
profiles i've developed over the past
year i know there is a lot of
misinformation about sony colors and we
don't really know how to set the camera
because it can be overwhelming when you
have so many options i really wanted to
share my knowledge with you so it's
easier to get good colors out of the
camera
these simulations are good days and can
be used straight out of the camera but i
believe you can always get more out of
your footage if you continue
post-processing
that's why i still recommend some color
grading and i prepared some luts for you
to get even closer to the film look
if you want to see a one-on-one
comparison video besides the profiles
just let me know in the comments and
i'll come back with a detailed video
don't forget to subscribe if you want to
be notified about the video hit the like
button or buy me a coffee if you
appreciate the content until next time
happy holidays and have a good one see
ya
[Music]
thank you
[Music]